What is that?
that
is london
Sixty minutes is all it took to bring humanity to the very brink of extinction
mankind mobilized a new age arose
the age
of the great predator city's
survival of the fastest
hey, watch out!
Valentine,
this is for my mother
stop her!
ask him why he murdered my mother?
No!
I'm sorry you had to hear that
as, to Shaw she won't stop until i'm dead
unless you kill her first
I want them found
get on
I've been looking for you for a long time
your mother, she said she had found something dangerous
she was afraid of valentine of what he might do
man who controls this controls the world
she said that you could stop him
this weapon can wipe out the largest city in the blink of an eye
not if we shut it down
nothing can stand in the face of this
we have to stop london before it destroys us
Are you sure you want to do this? once we go in there's no going back
I have to